good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight imagine dystopia you
hear that word frequently what does it
mean pictured in your mind's eye
dystopia is a world where the police
will not protect you they refuse and at
the same time you are not allowed to
protect yourself
so who does that leave in charge who
runs a world like that well young men
with guns they're in charge the cruelest
and most violent element of any society
the people with the least to lose
the shortest time Horizons
the shallowest reservoirs of impulse
control people like that have all the
power you have no power and that means
that everything you have is theirs
that's the end of civilization it exists
in Pockets around the world Mogadishu
famously
but if you think it's confined to
Mogadishu you haven't been to Chicago
lately
this past Friday just before noon a 30
year old man called Ryan King walked out
of a gym in Chicago's Bucktown
neighborhood Bucktown is a former polish
Enclave just west of Lincoln Park that's
one of the nicest parts of the city Real
Estate websites describe Bucktown as
young and hip a place where recent
college graduates who can pay above
average rents might live it's where your
kids might live with their friends as
they start their first jobs
that's what most people think of
Bucktown people who haven't been there
recently but local news accounts suggest
a very different reality shots fired
during Bucktown robbery man shot during
robbery attempt in Bucktown Bucktown
couple shares a count of armed robbery
and so on and on many stories like this
Ryan King probably wasn't thinking of
armed robbery as he walked out of the
gym on Friday it was broad daylight it
was a weekday
but then a car pulled up right next to
him three young men jumped out and stuck
a gun in his face
here's an account from local Fox station
in Chicago
Ryan Kane turned into an alley near the
corner of wabanzia in Oakley to get back
to his mother's apartment when a dark
colored vehicle pulls up and three young
men jump out king says one of them
pointed a gun right in his face
demanding his wallet and moments later
he says a passerby saw the mugging
unfolding and yelled instincts and his
martial arts training kicked in and
that's when King hit one of the men with
an elbow and ran off
again broad daylight middle of the day
nice neighborhood in one of America's
biggest cities so what happened next
well according to reporting by CWB
Chicago just minutes after Ryan King was
threatened with death for daring to walk
outside in his own neighborhood Chicago
Police spotted the gunman's vehicle
but there was nothing they could do
about it their supervisor ordered them
not to pursue it so the criminals just
drove off and of course they committed
more violent crimes in the hours after
Ryan King was attacked 16 more armed
robberies were reported in the area
police believe at least two organized
armed gangs are now operating with
impunity around Bucktown which means the
gangs are in charge now
that's what the collapse of civilization
looks like
but it's now normal in Chicago according
to data from the Chicago Sun Times
newspaper last year police made arrests
in just 12 percent of reported crimes
that's the lowest level recorded in
Chicago History and that's what it means
when politicians hand control of a city
to criminals here you run it
in Chicago right now taxpayers are more
likely to be the victims of crime than
criminals are to be punished for it so
the question is why would anyone in
Chicago pay taxes you'd have to be a
masochist to do that and pretty soon
only the masochist will be
so how did this happen well it's no
mystery there are many threads
but George Soros is a big one Soros paid
for this to happen so it was back to
prosecutor called Kim Fox who turned
Chicago over to the most vicious people
who live there not the decent good
people in all neighborhoods the most
vicious anti-social people the ones who
truly don't care about others willing to
kill people for their shoes or their car
the worst people and they run things now
this is from our Fox station in Chicago
clutching pictures of loved ones
families come together to share their
loss my sister name is Tiara Taylor
she died at 30 years old by the hands of
her husband it's been 336 days since the
murder of my son that was four years old
they're also United in their anger and
frustration that the killers of their
family members walk free they largely
blamed the office of the Cook County
State's Attorney and Kim Fox so we ask
you You Can Box how much longer do our
families need to suffer in pain and
sorrow with no justice for our loved
ones being served our children's blood
on your hands Miss Fox and I hope you
see their faces every night
you think Kim Fox cares I think she's
watching you think those scenes like
that penetrate at all
the shell of self-esteem that surrounds
her no of course not she doesn't care at
all
that's why she did it in the first place
someone should take action immediately
on that but she's not the only person
who did this the federal government also
played a role and you probably didn't
know what was happening over the eight
years of the Barack Obama administration
the Department of Justice forced more
than a dozen police departments around
the country to enter into something
called dissent decrees
chug was one of them the Obama
Administration began an investigation
into the Chicago police department and
they got a dissent consent decree now
all of these decrees took the same form
they pronounced police departments
guilty of racism if those departments
disproportionately interact with African
Americans regardless of whether those
interactions were legally justified in
other words the law is entirely
irrelevant
to the consent decree and so is reality
itself
here's a line from the doj dissent
decree imposed under Obama against
Chicago quote raw statistics show that
CPD Chicago Police Department uses Force
almost 10 times more often against
blacks than against whites
okay that's one data point it's not the
whole story it doesn't begin to tell the
whole story there was no analysis
whatsoever about whether the use of
force in these specific cases was
justified none
so this is not science they may have
graphs it's not science it's some kind
of crazed race ideology it's the equity
agenda
and in a fact and this of course was the
intended effect these consent decrees
have been a disaster for the people of
these cities
even in New Orleans whose mayor as we've
told you many times has driven that City
that beautiful city which is worth
Saving right into the sewer even the
Democratic mayor of New Orleans said
recently and we're quoting the consent
decrees handcuff are officers
that's an understatement at this point
New Orleans is essentially out of police
officers the median police response time
in New Orleans to 9-1-1 calls is over
two hours imagine armed people in your
home you call the police
two hours
a lot can happen in two hours that's the
total collapse of civilization there's
no reason to have a government
if the response time is two hours buy
your own guns establish your own order
that's we're going to be very soon
on a recent Friday night in that City
New Orleans one third year officer
called Scott Fanning just quit mid-shift
here's how he described it quote that
night I quit there are over 40 calls
holding when I logged into my computer
but there were only 35 Patrol officers
logged in for all eight districts in the
city some nights there was literally
been one person
in a big dangerous city
but it's not just New Orleans all over
the country police officer are quitting
and they're not being replaced
departments across the country say a
lack of officers is severely limiting
what they can respond to well routine
routinely respond to shootings but if
the person is going to survive we are
not going to follow up on that in
Philadelphia the department says it's
short more than 500 officers from before
the pandemic Los Angeles also missing
nearly 700 officers from its ranks
prompting the cancellation of its animal
cruelty unit and forcing officials to
shrink the size of its human trafficking
drug and gun units and more with
officers struggling to respond to just
serious felonies communities are
noticing an uptick in misdemeanors like
in Philly where more than 30 000
abandoned car complaints are going
unanswered
oh did you hear that so the forces of
compassion of caring the people who have
much more evolved consciences than you
do the people who put coexist in bumper
stickers on their Subarus those people
defunded the animal cruelty unit in Los
Angeles
so dogs can get tortured to death and
nobody cares and people too
and the cops who remain on those forces
by and large don't want to work there
because who would want to work there for
any amount of money
terrorizing the police with threats of
prosecution if they do their jobs
that's what the Democratic party has
done and the effect has been what it was
intended to be
depopulating police departments crimes
surged so in the end they didn't tell
you this but they succeeded in getting
rid of the police
and now politicians are submitting it
out loud in a lot of places they've
decided to just legalize crime here's
the mayor of Orland Park Illinois Keith
peacow describing the State's new safety
act watch this
as of January 1st 2023 the following
things will go into effect and people
need to be aware of this
it abolishes cash bail for almost every
offense this includes but isn't limited
to kidnapping armed robbery
second-degree murder drug-induced
homicide aggravated DUI threatening a
public official and aggravated fleeing
and eluding
and keep this in mind businesses and
homeowners officers will no longer be
able to remove trespassers from your
resident residents or your businesses
so how is this working exactly
is it such a low T country that no one's
going to do anything about this
politicians in Illinois just legalize
violent crime against you
and no one's done anything about a lot
of these people are going to be
re-elected in November really how does
that work where's the constituency for
violent crime in this country is there
really one is there anyone who's for it
other than like Kamala Harris and Ron
Clane and the audio logs who run this
Administration most people are not for
it even most Democrats are not for it
the safety act of Illinois stands for
safety accountability fairness and
Equity today
so
the reason they're doing this is because
they didn't like the demographic
breakdown of the people who were getting
arrested for crimes period this can't be
happening therefore they're just going
to redefine it away
it was ideologically inconvenient for
them
so the solution is just legalize murder
and kidnapping and trespassing and at
the same time you are not allowed to
notice that an awful lot of these cases
appear to be it's hard to know and you
never want to think it but they appear
to be motivated by racial animus
they do that's just true again no one
wants to think that but there are so
many videos of it consider the horrific
attack really an attempted murder on a
student at Westbrook High School in
Beaumont Texas really recently beaten
and nearly killed in a bathroom at
school what did he do wrong exactly we
don't know we can only guess but here's
the tape
[Music]
thank you
foreign
so that just can't be allowed in a
civilized country we cannot allow that
or anything like it to happen in our
country this is more important than
anything else that's happening because
that's Someone's Child
but everyone just stands by in our
country and lets it happen and in that
video in the men's room everyone stood
by and just filmed it snickered
the attacker of course is a repeat
offender he'd already been busted went
to jail they put him back in school and
that'll happen again you'll never know
his name
he's a juvenile attacker so he has a
right to go to school what about the
other kids in school they have no rights
so that means the bathroom at that
school in Beaumont Texas which is in the
United States is a pretty civilized
place you can't go there anymore that's
equity
having trouble eating out too
restaurants are suddenly out of control
is anyone noticing this here's footage
of a robbery at a restaurant in Los
Angeles from May
yeah
unbelievable
so
then there's this this is from
Providence this broke out recently this
scene at a place called me sueno
restaurant
completely out of control
so who has to deal with this well people
who have no choice but to eat at
Middleborough restaurants and don't have
their own private security
but the rich don't have to deal with it
because they know exactly what's going
on in many cases they vote for the
politicians who do this
and then they get people to protect them
armed with guns you're not allowed to
have because they have high capacity
magazines in New Orleans a real estate
developer called Sydney Torres Creator's
own police force he pays his dispatchers
20 grand a month we're not attacking him
he probably had no choice in Greenwich
Village in Manhattan residents and
businesses are paying eighteen thousand
dollars for two officers to patrol every
month
they're doing it why because they want
to spend the money no they pay taxes in
order to be protected but they have no
choice because police have abandoned New
York City too
the NYPD is releasing disturbing
surveillance videos almost every day
violent video after violent videos some
are hard to watch who could forget this
horrific shooting a gunman opening fire
on a bronx Street two children are
caught between the gunman and his Target
the shooter just continues shooting one
of the suspects was saying on
surveillance video pulling a gun on a 32
year old woman as she was returning home
from shopping the moments later second
suspect arrived police say they struck
the woman in the face they tied her up
stealing nineteen thousand dollars from
a safe and twelve thousand dollars worth
of Jewelry in this one you see a woman
being kicked from behind as she walks
down the steps of the Queen's Plaza
subway station in Long Island City she
is then hit over the head with a hammer
as many as 13 times as she is shoved to
the ground and robbed
so these crimes are so appalling they're
attacks not just on individuals but
against civilization and Humanity itself
that they at this point really do
require an immense and organized
non-violent civil Civil Disobedience
campaign
so just pick one of those videos at
random who's the prosecutor to let that
person out refuse to charge them in the
first place who's the politician who
decided that attacker had more rights
than the old lady he was beating up
why aren't fifteen thousand people
blocking that person's office or
chaining themselves to the front door of
it demanding an answer again why isn't
there massive non-violent Civil
Disobedience that can change this
barking about it on cable news clearly
isn't working we've been doing it for
five years
by the way it's not we give you examples
from La Chicago New York and you think
to yourself well yeah those are big
cities I left I opted out
I went somewhere nice and beautiful
somewhere like Asheville North Carolina
up in the mountains famously beautiful
place
you think you can get away from this in
Asheville North Carolina the once
beautiful mountain town
no you can't because it's there too in
2013 Asheville elected a new mayor a
lawyer called Esther Manheim she had the
now mandatory complicated eyeglasses
that all the girl bosses now wear
manheimer was never especially
interested in running the city of
Asheville that was very obvious she
didn't talk much about Asheville she
talked about can you guess can you guess
climate change and Equity by the way
anyone talks about climate change and
Equity is immediately disqualified from
getting your vote that should be the
rule right there that's like a baseline
climate change inequity no sorry you're
a lunatic
so by the way under mannheimer's
leadership Asheville promised 2.1
million dollars in reparations to Black
residents really how does that work and
how did it all work out well here are
the bottom line numbers from 2016 to
2020 violent crime in Asheville went up
by 31 Asheville is a beautiful place it
should have no crime
but as a lot now climate change Equity
really now we have a lot of carjackings
in Asheville overall car thefts went up
nearly 20 just last year across the
country
and they went up in Asheville so this
happened by accident if all the
politicians are talking about climate
change and equity and life for you gets
worse every single year maybe they're
doing it on purpose
here's footage from Wisconsin
Philadelphia and Detroit
a group of three young men wearing
sweatshirts appearing to case the home
about a minute later the trio enters the
backyard police tell us they stole car
keys a cell phone and a wallet and that
one of the men was holding a gun they
leave the backyard within 30 seconds as
someone from the party follows them out
then one of the suspects drives off in
this black Volkswagen SUV while another
runs down the sidewalk what you see in
this video is a carjacking in progress
police say two male suspects walk up to
a man sitting in this white Lexus open
the car door and force him out at
gunpoint the victim walks away as the
carjackers pull off his name is Michael
Brown he's around 15 or 16 and he's
identified as the suspect driver of this
stolen SUV as you can see the Yukon roll
over the top of the front of our car and
knocking over one of our officers seen
there on the ground to the right of the
Yukon
then the officer had to roll out of the
way as the Yukon tilted over top of our
Scout car nearly crushing our police
officer
so why is this continuing it's been
going on for more than two years since
George Floyd died in Minneapolis
Memorial Day 2020. why is it continuing
why has no one stopped it
because there's no one to stop it
dad's gone
there's no one in charge with a normal
testosterone level who's willing to just
say no you're not allowed to do this I'm
sorry you can't do that that's against
the law this is a country of laws
nothing personal we don't care what you
look like that's not allowed and if you
do we're going to spank your hearts you
don't do it again in other words no one
has shown up with clear and reasonable
rules and enforce them consistently when
that happens everybody calms down that's
true in the family and it's true in the
nation
and if you don't have that you have
chaos
armed robbers suddenly have a right to
be on your property murderers get out
without bail what are we looking at
we're looking at a war on the population
and it's time for real change this is
completely intolerable
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight